[Music]
[Applause]
give me the poll question and then we'll
get to Harold Reynolds Major League
Baseball network analyst
this weekend actually we're going with
how much opening day baseball did you
watch a whole lot I took a peek or none
I watched a whole lot let's bring in HR
who joins us now he was in studio
yesterday the two-time All-Star
three-time Gold Glove winner HR how
would you sum up opening day opening
night Major League Baseball
I thought it was awesome first of all
for the first time since 1968 every team
played that was the best part of the
whole day yeah
you know you remember when we were kids
Dan that Cincinnati Reds would play at
like 11 A.M it was like baseball's here
that's what I felt like yesterday it's
really cool I railed on this yesterday
being the buzz kill that I am now you
have all of these players you have all
these teams Everybody's In Action why is
shoheiotani hidden in Oakland to open up
the season
I'm with you that's just the way the
schedule is built I would love to seeing
him be the first guy out the gate man
his like something we've never seen and
he transcends the sport and that's what
you need right now and he had an inning
last night I stayed up and watched him
it was the fifth inning he got in a
little bit of a jam
and he threw three pitches to get out of
it 100 100
and 101. I mean it was like and he drove
in he got a base hit that set up their
only run that they scored in the game it
was fun to watch but do you believe in
that he's a 600 million dollar player is
he a 12-year 600 million dollars I don't
think it's gonna be 12 years I think it
might be 10. he's he's gonna get 600
plus I believe that and here's why
because if you watch the WBC and I know
people have argued whatever way they
want to the fact that he had a whole
country say it's a holiday we're in the
finals playing in America and show his
plan and they had 90 percent of Japan
launching that's every day when he plays
so that's where the money is the value
comes from you can make the argument hey
you gotta paying for a pitcher and it's
a DH and all that but to me the money
comes what do you draw and he draws it
internationally
but how do you get that money from the
international audience
I think you got to do a deal if you're a
team uh figuring out how to get his
games on TV over there okay and you're
marketing
but how do you keep those two guys
if if you're is is ohtani going to be on
the Angels by the end of the year
by the end of the year I think they're
still going to be in the race so I think
they keep him do I think he lives as a
free agent I've always felt that way I
don't see what changes it you know so I
I don't know he he won't be an angel
after this year I don't believe but if
you were going to say who can afford him
well there's a number of teams that can
afford him
because because of what I just said
you're gonna make your money back and
then something he's an incredible
investment but the the Dodgers don't let
him get out of town
I don't think so I I mean the way they
operate and Mark Walter's mindset as an
owner but they got another sheriff in
town and Steve Cohn and the Mets and
he's gonna he's gonna be right there
fighting with him so it's gonna be fun
to watch yeah that money is uh not off
to a rousing start with the Mets with uh
I mean all of a sudden you're going to
be I'm gonna spend all this money well
that guy's on the DL and that guy's on
the DL and that guy and that guy and not
pretty yeah I talked to Buck show altar
last night you know bucks always hey
next man up I'll figure it out but uh
you know they got they gotta survive
until they get Verlander will be back
probably three or four stars from now so
you get that going but Diaz is a big
blow yeah you know you're looking at 50
saves at the end of the game uh that's a
big blow I don't know how they replace
that all right let's recap the rules on
opening day and opening night okay and
do you think that they're going to be in
forced the same way in July because
sometimes we'll see this in other
leagues where they're going we're going
to crack down on pass interference we're
going to crack down on holding in the
NFL and then all of a sudden you get
late in the season you're like wait a
minute I thought you guys were calling
holding or past interference will these
umpires be this strict come July
well you you're you're a wise man Dan I
think there'll be adjustments along the
way but I do believe that the clock is
the clock 15 seconds is not going to
move to 20. you know it's not going to
move from 20 to 25 at the runaround base
I think those those numbers stay the
same but we had an incident last night
in Miami with the Mets where Peter
Alonso is on base he's running it's a
foul ball and McNeil's at the plate and
Pete Alonso takes a while to get back
and McNeil gets a strike those things
like that will be adjusted that's not in
the spirit of the rule so I think there
will be some adjustments along the way
and the players are going to get better
too you know Peter Lonzo playing the WBC
he wasn't around for four weeks he's
just moseying back
he'll jog back to the base next time so
I think there's going to be a Justice
with the players and umpires talking to
Harold Reynolds MLB network analyst I
don't want to overstate this and I know
this has been overstated before that
these rule changes this is this
commissioner's Legacy in my opinion yeah
but it might be the second most
important moment in baseball yet
integration which obviously changed the
game this is a change or changes that
need were needed
I just don't know how important they're
going to be as we look back 10 15 years
from now what do you think well I think
it's changed the game forever okay you
know I think it's bringing fans back
we're talking about baseball off the top
of your show this hour no I mean it's
it's changed the game and I think what's
going to happen if you go to a little
league game now they stand around and
just take the time games will never
played at that pace so they've changed
what happened yesterday games were cut
by almost a half an hour by average it's
the lowest since forever and then you
start looking at stolen bases yesterday
21 steals yesterday in the games that
hasn't happened since 1907 and Ricky
Henderson wasn't even playing them you
know so I mean all these things are
happening and what happens Dan you well
know this that being the basketball guy
that you are the shot clock started in
the NBA next thing you know you see it
in college then you see it in youth
basket ball and the same thing is going
to happen in baseball this is going to
be a trend that's going to change the
whole sport forever
your expectations for Aaron judge this
year are what
that was cool to see him hit that home
run yesterday
um he's gonna have some competition I I
think ohtania and trout they stay
healthy they're gonna be on him and
we're gonna see three guys Chase 60 plus
this year I think judge judges 40 home
runs when he wakes up that that that's
gonna happen so he set another standard
in another bar now and I think he's a
premier 50 60 Homer guy always great to
talk to you thanks for joining us and uh
we'll be watching all right
Yukon yeah all right yeah who do you
have
I got an upset man I got Florida
Atlantic
oh okay
all right yeah man uh there's no they're
the longest odds right now according to
uh DraftKings UConn prohibitive favorite
San Diego State Miami and then Florida
Atlantic yeah puts that pressure on you
man they press you they play that D yeah
it'll be fun yeah
thank you man thank you for having me
all right that's Harold Reynolds Major
League Baseball Network always ready